Let's go next to our caller from the 6 0 9
area code, 6 0 9.
Who's this?
Where you calling from?
A pack for a man, total control.
Someone got me.
Yes.
Total control, of course.
All right.
I'm mostly familiar with the movie, too, on
food.
But this first song they play and where is.
Sorry for what was not aware of the body.
Who?
I have no idea what you're talking about.
Yeah, I kind of was wondered if you ever saw
the movie or not.
It's a song that they play in it.
Basically, I want to know where all the bodies
we're talking about hundreds, sometimes even
thousands per day allegedly dying from.
Total control.
Are you there because you're at you're right
back in and out, my friend.
I'm guessing you don't believe the death toll
with little Beacon's Schutte.
We can cut to the chase.
You don't believe the death toll, right?
Yeah.
Dave, I think the connections on your end.
That's kind of choppy.
I do have questions about the death toll.
How come we can't see that the bodies, they
just simply don't show it's likely they will
take us inside the more trucks we see.
We see the bodies all the time, I mean, we
see the big veil over our bodies being loaded
into the into the refrigerated trucks.
Now I see why see one single body being rolled
into a big empty trailer.
I see close cropped video of the E.R. floors.
It's usually the same video played over and
over again.
But like this day, put it like this.
I'm a homeless advocate.
Right.
And.
Dear God.
All right, total control.
There you go.
Listen.
And others have ringing it.
Goodness.
Everything.
Everything going wrong.
Listen, total control.
What we see videos all the time of the bodies
being loaded up.
It's horrible.
It's tragic.
We've seen it all over the world.
We've seen the images from Italy of them having
to use churches, too.
I mean, it's tragic what's going on.
And if your focus now is going to be to argue
that nobody's really dying, I just don't really
have that much time for you.
We've got bigger fish to fry and more important
things going on.
OK, let me go next to our caller from the
2 1 9 area code who is calling today from
2 1 9.
Hey, David, it's Matt calling from Minneapolis.
Hey, Matt.
What's up?
Yeah.
So my question is in regards to the mental
health effects on the coronavirus locked down.
Putting a lot of.
Sorry.
Putting under pressure and your mental health
and mental health experts are talking about
how suicide rates spiked during the last recession.
And I'm wondering if you've heard or if you
propose any way to mitigate some of these
affect, whether it's policy or just kind of
talk that you support?
I'm actually very worried about this.
I'm worried about it as well.
I think it has to be community support.
And also, we need to see governors and the
president leading on this because, you know,
a lot of the infrastructure that's required
takes a little while to get set up.
So one thing that I saw, one congressman did
was a congressman set up a phone number.
People can basically call if they are, you
know, struggling emotionally.
And I guess he got like a thousand calls or
something like that.
This is very much needed.
What I would like to see is from the president
and governors and public health officials.
Dr. Burke, Dr. Foushee, everybody should be
saying a lot of people are likely not feeling
well because of what's going on emotionally.
Let's all be in touch.
Make yourself available to others.
Make sure you tell others if you're not doing
well and you want to get on the phone or Skype
or whatever.
I don't know how much more we can do, but
I would love to be hearing it daily in every
briefing from a governor, mayor and the president.
Yeah, actually, I was reading on Mother Jones
this morning how some of the mental health
hotlines they saw, they saw a Spike scholarship
last month.
So it's no surprise a big deal.
Yeah.
We've got to deal with it.
All right, my friend.
Thank you so much.
Something very screwy.
I think that there be something maybe going
on with our phone system from the number of
people that are calling in and maybe the number
of people that are using phones because of
the virus.
I have no idea what's going on, but we're
dealing with it as best we can.